.
THAT IS DESPITE THE FACT THAT
VACCINES HAVE BEEN MOST OF THE
YEAR.
ANGER OVER NEW COVID
RESTRICTIONS, LEADING TO
PROTEST ACROSS EUROPE.
SOME OF THEM, VIOLENT.
A NATIONWIDE LOCKDOWN, GOING
INTO EFFECT IN AUSTRIA, WHERE A
VACCINE MANDATE, EXPECTED, IN
FEBRUARY.
THOUSANDS RALLIED AGAINST
MANDATORY VACCINES, AND
CERTIFICATES, AND POLICE, IN
BRUSSELS, USE OF WATER CANNON
TO DISPERSE THE PROTESTS
AGAINST A BAN ON UNVACCINATED
PEOPLE, FROM SOME VENUES.
AND, IN THE NETHERLANDS, A
PARTIAL LOCKDOWN IS UNDERWAY.
MANY PEOPLE, FRUSTRATED BY
MONTHS OF RESTRICTIONS, AND,
THEY ARE LASHING OUT.
FOR MORE ON THIS, WE WANT TO
BRING IN A PROFESSOR AND
BIOMEDICAL, AND LIFE SCIENCES,
AT THE UNIVERSITY COLLEGE.
JOINING ME NOW, FROM TILL
BERGEN, THE NETHERLANDS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
WITH US.
>> THANK YOU, GOOD MORNING.
>> SO, ALL OF THE DATA, AND ALL
OF THE EVIDENCE, SHOWING THAT
THESE COVID VACCINES WORK, AND
YET, ACROSS EUROPE, AND INDEED,
THE UNITED STATES, ARE PUSHING
BACK, MORE PEOPLE EMPOWER
NATIONS, CONTINUING, TO GET
ACCESS TO THESE SAME VACCINES.
WHY IS THERE SO MUCH RESISTANCE
TO THE SHOTS?
HOW DO YOU OVERCOME THIS
ANTI-VAX SENTIMENT?
>> THAT IS A DIFFICULT QUESTION,
AND THIS IS NOT ONE THAT GOES
WITH THIS VACCINATION.
WE HAVE AT LEAST 3 DIFFERENT
REASONS FOR TO VACCINATE, NOT
TO BECOME VACCINATED.
ONE, IS BASED ON RELIGION, AND
IN OUR SO-CALLED GENERAL LOW
UPTAKE OF ANY VACCINE,
INCLUDING THE CORONA VACCINE,
SO THERE IS ONE.
SO, IT IS MIGRATING DOWN, AND
IT IS ENSURING THAT IT IS ALSO
THE LOW UPTAKE.
CERTAINLY, THERE IS DISTRUST.
THAT IS WHAT I HEARD, IS THAT
IF THEY WOULD GET VACCINATED,
THAT WAS A MEANT BY THE
GOVERNMENT TO KILL THEM.
IT WAS AN ACT TO KILL THEM.
SO, REALLY, IT IS ALMOST
INCOMPREHENSIBLE.
THEN, WE HAVE THE ANTI-VAXXERS
WHO, ARE ON ALL KINDS OF WEIRD
REASONS, AND CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, ABOUT BIG PHARMA, OR
BILL GATES.
YOU HAVE THE SAME IN THE U.S..
IT IS A VERY VOCAL, ACTIVE
GROUP, AND NO MATTER WHAT YOU
TRY.
>> MISINFORMATION, BEING RIGHT
AT THE CENTER OF ALL OF, THAT
APPARENTLY.
KHORASAN INTO THICK EVIDENCE,
AND IN THE 3RD BOOSTER SHOT IS
THE ANSWER, TO STOPPING COVID,
IN ITS TRACKS.
WHAT IS YOUR VIEW ON GETTING
THOSE OPEN TO BEING VACCINATED,
THAT 3RD BOOSTER SHOT?
GIVEN THAT IT WAS JUST APPROVED,
HERE IN THE U.S., FOR ALL OF
THOSE ADULTS, 18, AND OLDER.
>> WE ARE A BIT LATE.
WE HAVE JUST STARTED WITH THE
80 PLUS TO GET A BOOSTER
VACCINATION.
SO, I THINK THAT MOST PEOPLE,
WHO DID GET 2 SHOTS, ALSO, WANT
TO TAKE 3 SHOTS.
BUT, THE ARGUMENT THAT THEY
WOULD MEET IN ADDITIONAL, AND
IT IS IN THE ANTI-VACCINE
MOVEMENT.
SO, IT WAS WITH THEIR MAKING AT
WORK, AND IN THE, 4TH AND THE
5TH, AND WHERE IN THE END.
>> IT WAS HOW THEY HAD BEEN
TREATMENT, AND HOW THEY WOULD
BECOME AVAILABLE, TO MOST
PEOPLE, EVENTUALLY.
HOW COMFORTABLE ARE YOU WITH
THE VARIOUS COVID PILLS?
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF COMPANIES
PUTTING THESE OUT.
THEY ARE BEING APPROVED.
WILL THEY HELP THOSE WHO RESIST
THEIR VACCINE?
COULD THOSE PILLS, EVENTUALLY,
TURN THIS AROUND?
ALONG WITH THE VACCINES, OF
COURSE, FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE ACCEPTED THE SCIENCE ON
THIS?
>> YES.
WE WILL HAVE TO, SEE OF COURSE,
HOW EFFECTIVE THOSE PILLS WILL
BE.
I HAVE GOOD HOPES THAT IT IS
EFFECTIVE.
FOR THE RELIGIOUS GROUP, THAT
REFUSES VACCINATION, THEY DO
ACCEPT TREATMENT.
SO, FOR THEM, IT WILL BE GOOD.
ALSO, OF COURSE, FOR EVERYONE
WHO IS VACCINATED, BUT BECAUSE
OF THEIR WEAK IMMUNE SYSTEM,
STILL, THEY COULD BE
VULNERABLE.
SO, I ASSUME THAT EVERYONE
WANTS TO REMAIN HEALTHY.
AND, IF YOU ARE POSTVACCINATION,
YOU WILL STILL GO TO THE
HOSPITAL, OR TO YOUR GENERAL
PRACTITIONER, AND HAVE YOURSELF
TREATED.
SO, I THINK, THAT ADEQUATE
TREATMENT, NOW, FOR THIS
HORRIBLE DISEASE, WILL,
CERTAINLY, HAVE ITS IMPACT.
>> LET'S HOPE PEOPLE CAN BE
SMART, AND TURN THIS AROUND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US, AND THANK YOU FOR TALKING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> VACCINE MISINFORMATION,
TAKING A TRAGIC TOLL, IN MUCH
OF EASTERN EUROPE.
VACCINATION RATES WERE LOW
THERE, AND IN WESTERN EUROPE.
THE PROBLEM WAS ESPECIALLY
ACUTE IN ROMANIA, AND IT WAS
FULLY VACCINATED, AND IT WAS
ALMOST VACCINATION RATES IN
EUROPE.
THERE WERE SUFFERING ONE OF THE
HIGHEST MORTALITY RATES IN THE
WORLD.
IT WAS WITH HOSPITALS, AND
MORGUES, ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
CNN'S BEN WEDEMAN, JOINING ME,
AND WITH KRISTEN IRANIAN.
THERE WAS A LOT OF ANTI-VAX
SENTIMENT, ACROSS THE GLOBE,
AND WHO IS PARTICULARLY EVIDENT,
AND IT WAS CONTRIBUTING REGIONS
FOR WHY THE VACCINATION RATE IS
SO LOW.
WHAT ARE THE MAIN REASONS FOR
THE MAIN RESISTANCE THERE?
>> MISS ROSEMARY, IT IS A
LETHAL COMBINATION, AND IT IS
SUPERSTITION, AND SUSPICION,
ALL OF, WHICH HAVING BEEN
STOKED BY SOME RELIGIOUS
FIGURES, AND IT IS POLITICIANS
WHO, ARE BASICALLY, TAKING ALL
OF THOSE FACTORS EVEN WORSE.
THIS, DESPITE THE FACT THAT
ROMANIA GOT OFF TO A GOOD START,
AND HOW THE VACCINATION,
PROGRAM LAST YEAR.
IT WAS AMONG EUROPEAN COUNTRIES,
THAT HAS THE 2ND LOWEST
VACCINATION RATE.
JUST AFTER BULGARIA.
NOW, THE NUMBERS, ARE STARTING
TO GO DOWN.
THIS IS ROMANIA'S 4TH WAVE.
THE NUMBERS, STARTING TO GO
DOWN, AND THAT, IRONICALLY, HAS
PROMPTED THE CABINET, WHICH IS
COMPOSED, A CARETAKER CABINET,
COMPOSED OF A SHAKY COALITION,
TO CONSIDER THE POSSIBILITY OF
RELAXING SOME RESTRICTIONS.
CLEARLY, THEY ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS SORT OF UNREST, AND
THIS OPPOSITION, THAT COMES
FROM THE STREETS IN WESTERN
EUROPE, AND TO STRICTER
MEASURES.
THEY ARE PUTTING POLITICS,
BEFORE PUBLIC SAFETY, WHEN IT
COMES TO, TRYING, TO BRING THIS
PANDEMIC UND